les dinosaures envahissent et la france
pour la sortie officielle du film
jurassic park qui comme tout les
superproductions américaines est érigée
en véritable phénomène de société une
vague déferlante de dinosaures magna
ça y est ils sont arrivés ils sont chez
nous hante nos supermarchés en prenant
les formes les plus inattendues ces
créatures enfin moi je voulais parler
d'autres créatures nettement moins
affriolante les dinosaures de steven
spielberg
parce que derrière jurassic park et son
insupportable opération marketing il ne
faut pas oublier qu'il y ait un film
événement
qu'est ce qui vous intéresse en chine
j'ai pas joué avec des copines alors que
je vous raconte au cas où vous ne
l'auriez pas compris jurassic park c'est
un film sur les dinosaures et puis ya
deux ans il veut le dimanche le pied et
afia elle ya le bonhomme il il la prend
et le combat le braille latière elle dès
lors il vient tout de suite des attaques
vers l'écran d'accord d'accord on a
compris il savait leur rendement bien
c'est vraiment super la fin c'est bien
mais le début on comprend pas trouvé bon
de faust a un peu triché verhagen
je sais bien joué j'ai bien aimé vous
faites les effets spéciaux il était bien
on s'en rend pas compte c'est bien la
peine qu'ils se donnent du mal spielberg
a aimé les effets spéciaux ouest recours
cannes est un film j'écoutais à tout le
monde approché ne craignez rien
je vérifie coton dinosaures et bien
tatoué jurassic park
laventure de la préhistoire c'est
maintenant et je tâche facile faut-il
avoir peur de jurassic park à deauville
en pleine controverse ou l'exception
culturelle jacques toubon attaque le
film bilan telle erreur de communication
qui encourage un cliché dévastateur dans
l'esprit du grand public d'un côté le
cinéma hollywoodien supposé être un
produit attractif et populaire de
l'autre les filmant roque ler oeuvre
d'art un peu ennuyeux décrété ainsi
symbole de l'arrogance américaine
jurassic park et pourtant est avant tout
une démonstration de savoir faire
commercial alors que je filmais à
grantham est à peine le tournage des
premières scènes les négociations dans
le monde entier sur les produits dérivés
avaient déjà commencé trop d'argent
étaient à prendre cette affaire pour que
le phénomène ne deviennent irrésistibles
et ce n'est qu'un début
il y aura d'autres produits le film
sortira en vidéo cassettes donc bien
évidemment je pense que et il y aura
toujours une nouvelle génération
d'enfants qui sera attirée vers les
dinosaures donc nous réfléchissons à
tous ces problèmes là
voici rassemblés sur cette table la
centaine de produits créés à l'occasion
de la sortie du film le logo lui est
partout sur les bus les consoles vidéo
et même les peaux diao
tout le monde pousse dans le même sens
le film sera demain à la fiche dans plus
de 400 salles de cinéma les exploitants
réfute pourtant l'accusation de faire le
jeu des américains
j'estime qu'il est absolument pas
contradictoire de diffuser des films
américains et de réclamer des conditions
économiques saines pour qu'un cinéma
européen puisse exister dans de bonnes
conditions
c'est pour mes enfants c'est pas vu le
film c'est peut-être une merde dans ce
cas-là ça servira pour la voiture
et puis la dendre beaucoup
[Musique]
un circuit en a vu dessine moi un mouton
tu parles dessine moi plutôt un
velociraptor un dinosaure ou encore un
tyrannosaure mais pas un mouton car ça y
est il est sorti ce film celui dont on
nous parle depuis des mois le dernier
spielberg et les dinosaures sont partout
dans la presse bien sûr et même jusque
sur les paquets de bonbons et justement
alors que l'on annonce que le
gouvernement revendique une exception
culturelle dans les accords du gatt avec
les américains mais alors tous ces gens
qui se précipitent pour voir jurassic
park sont ils des traîtres le gatt et
l'exception culturelle ça vous dit
quelque chose
le gatt
accord qu
on en a parlé on est ce assez majin
agreements dans le cadre
de l'exception culturelle je vais voir
justement c'est fini pour me faire une
idée
les films américains normalement je
n'étais pas parti pour le voir je
voulais aller voir
le gâte c'est comment dire avec
l'amérique en france contre l'amérique
pour
la culture entre autres les cinémas et
les cinémas américains ya une guerre
quand même bien qu'il produit pour le
cinéma une guerre car mon pays en guerre
ce que c'est pas parce que ces
américains que je dois pas aller le voir
et gâte ou pas gâte spielberg et toutes
façons à son public et c'est parti pour
son film en france et pour plusieurs
semaines
[Musique]